i wasn't going to make a video today but
i was going through my patreon messages
and i saw this one here this person is
trying to learn about game engines and
opengl and programming in general
they've asked for advice on discord
people just say to do the hazel series i
can't tell you what it is but i kind of
like the sparky series better i think
because it's perhaps a bit less
professional thus feels like more my
level i really can't tell you why
because the hazel series is awesome but
i wanted your thoughts on the
differences in getting the most out of
your teachings would you still recommend
sparky to people now normally i would
kind of say no not really sparky was
more or less like my first game engine
i've made kind of other smaller ones in
the past but i actually managed to make
a game with sparky for like some lotum
dare a lot of my earlier content kind of
centers around sparky was a game engine
that i wrote in c plus plus it supported
opengl and directx 11 and we could even
compile it into javascript and webgl so
that you could play your games in a web
browser that's right c plus plus engine
compiled into javascript beautiful i was
reading this message and i realized that
a large number of you who have only
found my channel recently probably don't
even know what sparky is and might not
even remember those days but there was
an entire video series like a series of
live streams dedicated for sparky
because basically it was an engine that
came out of me only having about 40 days
before the next lotum dare and i really
wanted to actually have my own engine to
make games i really didn't want to use
like unity or unreal i still wanted to
kind of make the game from scratch in a
way because that's what i did every
single atom there i would kind of start
with like a completely blank project in
a programming language and just build
the whole game like without any engines
you know from scratch so i'd build the
engine and the game basically within
like that 48 hour block which of course
was challenging and i thought well if
people are using unity why don't i like
create some kind of base tech of my own
that i can then use to make the game and
hence sparky was born so 40 days is when
the bulk of that engine was written not
like the latest stuff that came like
directx 11 and all that but the the kind
of core was written essentially within
like the 40 days and i made i think 25
or so episodes out of that and that
became like the sparky series on youtube
now because it was made in 40 days and
because i think it's about six years old
at this point obviously like my skills
and capabilities now are much better
than they were back then like back then
i was still learning like a lot actually
no 2015 so it's like seven years so it's
been like over seven years since sparky
like began absolutely crazy but anyway
the point is that the code for sparky
doesn't work out of the box it seems now
i haven't tried running sparky in years
um apparently people are still trying to
do that they've tried to get sparky to
run multiple times to check it out i was
even recommended to try the last build
correlated to the last tutorial series
from discord but it seems a few in your
discord said it's all outdated they
can't get it to run either just to hazel
so this is news to me because i have no
idea why it doesn't run first of all but
also reading this message on like a
friday morning knowing that i don't have
a video this week at all because i'm too
busy working on actual programming and
sometimes when i'm too focused on like
the software engineering side of things
it's really really difficult to make
videos which is why i'm considering
making like a little studio channel
weekly newsletter or something like that
maybe like a little blog something very
very simple that i can just push updates
to for those of you who are interested
so that you know that we're not doing
nothing but anyway i just thought it
would be a cool idea to try and revisit
sparky and run it and fix it i don't
know what's wrong with it i have not
like literally haven't looked at it in
years so let's go ahead and just try and
download it and see what happens ensure
the future of your work consider
inviting another github user to be your
successor that's how old this is github
is like dude you're probably gonna die
soon so like maybe you should give
someone else your account details that
is hilarious okay anyway so yeah you can
see like seven years ago six years ago
this is sparky it's completely free
obviously on github
github.com it'll be a link in
description below for those of you who
dare to like take a look at it oh this
brings back memories look at that logo
look at that beautiful little thing i'd
made in after effects just absolutely
amazing now there are different branches
though there's quite a lot actually um
so i think master's not even the most
up-to-date one i don't know if it's like
maybe the desert development branch that
might be more up to date well eight
years ago it's even even worse i think
there's like
oh is it 3d oh cli and see a ligen and
oh man this just this brings back so
many memories okay i'm gonna go with
this master branch because i think
that's probably where it's at okay let's
go ahead and clone it i don't think we
need to recursively clone it i'm pretty
sure i didn't use sub modules for that
there's even an android branch yeah i
think this supported android actually to
some extent yes it did i managed to find
this tweet so this was what may 2015
this very very cool like little photo
here of my galaxy note 4 which by the
way was an absolute pile of garbage draw
calls on these graphics drivers
literally took like twice as long as any
other android device out there like back
when we were trying to ship need for
speed no limits at ea like this was like
a problem device like ever the game
would just run at 15 fps on this and
like 30 everywhere else like it was just
the i don't know what what they did with
like the gpu and the drivers here but it
was an absolute disaster i remember that
but anyway this is like a lot of quads
rendering with like some kind of light
happening presumably so yes it did
support android those were the days okay
let's go ahead and see what happens now
this actually okay so this doesn't have
like a build system this just comes with
a visual studio solution and then it's
got a bunch of dependencies here so i'm
assuming that if we try and open this
um in like visual studio 2022 uh it's
open on my other monitor but let's go
ahead and like try and upgrade this to
like the latest compiler and everything
because we'll have to i don't have like
visual studio what was this probably
like
2015 yeah i think this was like visual
studio 2015 or something um anyway it's
up it looks like it's updated everything
so we don't really care about a lot of
these things like sparky cli let's go
ahead and like unload
these projects because that's just like
the c sharp interface which it also had
using c cli sparky core is all over here
inside this so let's maybe try and
like build the dependencies or something
and we'll see what happens oh man this
is like win32 it's building in win32
that's great this isn't even 64-bit okay
well all of that succeeded is let's
build sparky core now but what if this
just works like
i wonder if sparky cli and cs might not
compile i don't know
but i hope that's not the reason why
people have been saying it doesn't work
because like these unrelated projects
that you don't need to run don't work so
we'll see
um but yeah this is sparky it doesn't
look like
i don't know if it's using parallel
build i'm not okay well that totally
worked um and then we'll build sandbox i
guess maybe we'll get some linking
errors because i think sparky core is
actually sparky core is a dll so that i
think links everything into itself yeah
it's a dll so that would have linked
everything so we're in debug let's just
go ahead and run sandbox
and it totally works what a pile of
garbage i hate the community sometimes
what are you talking about it doesn't
work okay so this is using directx 11.
um this is there's a 3d test as well so
we've got target screen post effects off
we've got a number of allocations and
memory stuff here 2000 fps cool
um i'm guessing resizing and stuff works
well that's a bit blur down little font
test here beautiful i think if we go
into um
let's see here if we go into like
sandbox yeah we can push these different
layers on so test2d was what you saw
there but we can push test 3d on and
then test 3d
is going to be like some kind of 3d
scene yeah beautiful everything works
perfectly of course it does anyway um
and then you can see this is some like
really probably not very good physically
based rendering performs really well
though um but this is some uh yeah i
don't know what's going on how do i zoom
in okay here we go yeah we've got like
some kind of
uh some rougher materials here we've got
what looks like an a normal map and
obviously like a roughness map as well
because you can see these kind of
lulls
this is so fun to look at now um you can
see this kind of lulls um
uh you know just i just a texture i made
in photoshop that's probably like the
roughness map and also looks like
there's some general normals or
something going on here uh and then we
got like yeah we've got these kind of
materials here which we've got
dielectrics so like plastics and
metal here of varying roughnesses as you
would have
looks a little weird
like the curve's a bit weird but sure
um
yeah and then we've got like a sponsor
test as well we've got some kind of
deferred rendering test but i think that
doesn't work yeah
okay so this is sponsor loading we've
got some nice large juicy large
allocations going on here and of course
that works as well
at 0.5 milliseconds per frame
look at this beautiful
what's going on here
you got you guys and your like lack of
projects working like i literally just
ran this like it could not be easier i
don't understand why people why are
people knocking sparky it clearly works
perfectly uh let's try opengl though so
at the moment you can see we can select
direct 3d right let's go back to the
test 3d because it'll load a lot faster
let's try like a different render api so
let's try opengl instead and then i'm
assuming that this will probably also
just work although this is seemingly
giving us some errors but no that also
works 0.3 milliseconds per frame
you know
yeah it seems pretty good
okay so there are some
all right so it looks like some kind of
uh seamless cube maps or whatever aren't
turned on in opengl that might be the
reason for this although i have no idea
how we're filtering this and there seems
to be some kind of shader bug probably
like a nan or something causing that
little black dot in the middle which
yeah i mean directx just looks better
than opengl right so let's just go back
to that we'll forget about opengl
completely so yeah that is that is the
sparky engine i mean i mean like of
course you can probably there is
probably additional features and all
that stuff in like the other branches i
imagine we've got like a little virtual
file system here if we go to test 3d
this was the actual test now this is
going to be disgusting just a fair
warning uh this is ch this is ceno like
as like how old was i back then like 20
21 or something this is me as like a
completely clueless person
um
yeah everything's set up manually
through code i think that was kind of
the point there's no editor or anything
like that hazel is an enormously
better experience than than sparky of
course but like yeah i mean i guess it
kind of works the entity component
system i'm pretty sure is not an
anti-component system i'm pretty sure
it's just like yeah it just stores
everything just like that um like there
is no kind of
components are not stored together i
think it's like per entity kind of thing
i think entities just have components
because i was going to make an
anti-component system eventually but uh
i didn't get around to that i mean
that's kind of it i think there's even
like i don't know if this works in this
version of sparky
but there's also like a way i think to
build it
so spm build oh yeah that's right so we
have our own 3d model format here as
well spm build builds it so spm build is
this kind of cool utility that uses the
fbx sdk
to basically generate like a sparky
model file that's probably why it loads
so quickly as well um because it just
generates like a
like a an spm file i think sparky model
format um so that's what that's what
that is but there's there was some kind
of like i'm pretty sure maybe it's like
in lol docs oh look there's like some
release notes
damn look at this we don't even really
have this for hazel remove journalcraft
oh man look at this so much so many
features so many major new
new changes
there it is sparky model nice yeah cool
um so that was kind of exciting ah here
it is it's in the bin directory so
there's an em build sparky.bat
which basically
uh will build sparky using m scriptin
which is how we get it to compile to
javascript and i think there are some
kind of yeah see soundmanage.js this is
like because for sounds i think we had
to
patch that in manually and i think if we
go to like sound yeah this supports
everything like again we're like
technically speaking i shipped a game
using this right like i made a game for
lotum dare released it people could play
it in a web browser like it worked with
sound with everything so technically
this is like in a way it's like a little
bit feature complete i guess like it's
capable of actually working but yeah we
had like some kind of specialized
if sparky platform web defines here
which i think were basically patched
into those javascript
uh like functions that you saw
sparky.html
here we go
this is it look it's running it's
running
it's running opengl web 1.0 we can move
the uh mouse around
to illuminate like what we see here this
is like kind of i guess a bit of test 2d
or whatever there you go running in a
web browser i'm very surprised it's like
still works but i guess why wouldn't it
so like everything works man all right
so then the last thing that might not
build are these things that i like
immediately unloaded um so let's reload
them and then let's just try and build
sparky cli okay this doesn't seem to
build right looks like due to like an
include path and then i'm guessing
because of that sandbox cs won't build
because it's trying to build sparky cli
so really like i mean if we just disable
these two projects like if we just if
you just unload those two i mean you
don't have to unload them you can just
build sandbox and just run sandbox right
like you don't need to build those two
projects sandbox cs is like a completely
different application that you can see
tries to use like the c-sharp api um and
then i guess that doesn't work just
because
yeah because some include path or
whatever doesn't exist
we could probably fix that if we were
like serious about it
sparky's cli for those of you who are
interested is basically just a wrapper
using simple cli which is like kind of
like a
it's kind of like a garbage collected c
plus plus language it's a bit of a
frankenstein thing by microsoft um but
yeah
you've got some fancy things here like
hats ah simple cli and so yeah that just
lets us kind of access the complete like
c plus api but through c sharp so anyway
moral of the story don't trust the
community